dieter nuhr was haben alle mit ihm er
ist doch nur dieter ich hab das ungute
gefühle was ziemlich dummes zu machen
nämlich ein differenziertes video über
dieter nuhr
denn der mann ist so polarisieren warum
das sagte jetzt schon des videos hat
auch nicht mehr ankomme
willkommen zur bei lab drama analyse
falls ihr das drama um dieter nuhr und
die deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft
nicht mitbekommen habt hier in kürze
recap alle anderen können hier unten zur
nächsten kapitel sprechen die deutsche
forschungsgemeinschaft die dfg möchte
mit ihrer aktuellen kampagne gemeinsam
hashtag für das wissen überzeugung für
eine freie und erkenntnis geleitete
forschung in die gesellschaft tragen die
deg sammelt kurze statements in denen
sich verschiedene menschen für das
wissen aus sprechen darunter auch dieter
nuhr letzte woche donnerstag wurden ua
statement gepostet and people were not
having niemand braucht seine position um
die klimaziele zu wissen dass alle
mitgemacht jetzt gerade der knaller
gewesen
unter ihrem ich entscheiden um ihn so zu
inszenieren ich glaube nicht dass eine
schlechte wahl war china die tiere ich
glaube aber dass sicherheit und heute
bessere kandidatin gegeben hätte als
jemanden der wissenschaft aktiv
absolvieren scheint am nächsten morgen
meldete sich die dfg zurückbekommen die
kritiker kommentare und hinweise ernst
und haben die beitragspflicht an der
kampagne bezeichnet wird
and people were weltstandard
genossenschaften garantiert ich weiß
noch dass ich dich da passt manchen
leuten araber eines ponys nicht voran
konnten die sg wirklich distanzieren und
sie tut es gibt die fdp bereitet von
herrn huber sachlich und richtig nicht
er mag an äußerungen eines videos
befinden
aber deswegen richtige aussage zur sache
ist zwischenergebnis neuen
wissenschaftlichen des kurses
wohlgemerkt gab es sowohl gegen nur als
auch gegen die dfg viele nicht so
sachliche beschimpfungen und
beleidigungen die ich jetzt hier
natürlich nicht wiederholen oder
einblenden werde aber ihr könnt euch
denken dass in dem storm einiges an
steht war hier bleiben wir immer
sachlich und entspannt deswegen holt
durch meinetwegen auch im asc für den
extra chill macht es euch gemütlich los
geht's
so freunde der sonne wie analysieren das
drama heute unter 5 gesichtspunkten das
jetzt quasi ein drama in fünf akten als
1 nein nein das ist normal hören uns
erst mal an was nur in seinem statement
im o ton gesagt hat wissen bedeutet
nicht dass man sich zu hundert prozent
sicher ist sondern dass man über
genügend schatten verfügt um eine
begründete meinung zu haben weil viele
menschen gleich sind wissenschaftler
ihre meinung ändern nein das ist normal
wissenschaft ist gerade dass sich die
meinung ändert wenn sich die faktenlage
ändert wissenschaft es nämlich keine
heilslehre keine religion die absolute
wahrheiten verkündet und wer ständig ruf
folgt der wissenschaft der hat das
offensichtlich nicht begriffen
wissenschaft weiß nicht alles ist aber
die einzige vernünftige wissensbasis die
wir haben deshalb ist es so wichtig
moment mal habe ich das schon mal gehört
wissenschaft ist nicht die wahrheit
aber sie ist die beste näherung die uns
zur verfügung steht wissenschaft
bedeutet fortlaufend neue erkenntnisse
zu gewinnen
die open legen sich auf einem arm fest
die experimente können neue erkenntnisse
bringen die dazu führen dass man alles
was man bisher als war angenommen hatte
wie der in frage stellen muss ist ist
dieter nuhr ein freund der sonne
nein also wer weiß vielleicht ist das
ich will damit nur sagen es ist kein so
großer zufall dass wir uns darüber
schneiden ein heim das ist ganz normal
sind statements sehr konform ist mit dem
was viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftskommunikatoren sagen weil
es einfach stimmt warum dann die kritik
akt zwei art homini die kritik an nur
statement lässt sich vielleicht am
kürzesten in dieser reaktion
zusammenfassen wer unwissenschaftlichen
blödsinn erzählt soll nicht mit seinem
gesicht für die dfg und für das wissen
stehen so das argument einige halten
aber auch dagegen und zwar nicht nur
fans nicht nur fans die sagen man muss
ja seine comedy nicht mögen aber wo er
recht hat hat er doch recht wie
unwissenschaftlich nur tatsächlich ist
das schauen wir uns in teil drei und
vier an klären wie hier ist mal eine
grundsatzfrage ist der backlash gegen
uhr
ein argument also ein angriff gegen eine
person und keine argumentation in der
sache das ist wie kreatin berg
anzugreifen anstatt sich mit
klimaforschung auseinander zu sagen ja
es gibt auch situationen wo das trennen
zwischen argument und person nicht
möglich oder nicht sinnvoll ist zum
beispiel bei solchen statements
natürlich geht es hier um die sache also
für das wissen aber der witz bei solchen
statements ist ja eben das prominente
personen mit ihrer person mit ihrem
gesicht für diese sache stehen und so
lange man dieter nuhr nicht als person
angreift sondern seine öffentlichen
aussagen also seine inhalte kritisiert
ist es gerechtfertigt sich daran zu
stören wenn diese inhalte nicht
konsistent sind also wenn er zum
beispiel in seinem bühnenprogramm sich
gegen die wissenschaft ausspricht und
dani diesem statement dafür aber macht
er das denn akt 3 die gretchenfrage nur
sag wie hast du's mit der wissenschaft
ich hab noch nie wissenschaftlich
argumentiert sagte selbst wissenschafts
feindlich ist für mich zumindest auch
ein sehr starkes wort das würde ich
jetzt nur für wirklich harte
wissenschafts verweigerer verwenden
aber wie steht nur zu wissenschaft
regelmäßig behandelt er
wissenschaftliche themen und teilt dabei
auch kritik aus was grundsätzlich nicht
verkehrt ist aber ist diese kritik
angemessen für jemanden der sich großer
freund der wissenschaft nennt
ich habe mir ein paar seiner neueren
auftritte vom letzten halben jahr
angeschaut und drei wiederkehrende
kritikpunkte festgestellt erst auf
feinstaub klimawandel oder kroner wir
sind zu hysterisch berufen über nichts
anderes gerät ist für feinstaub und
stickoxide bis man es nicht mehr hören
konnte und jetzt interessiert sich
plötzlich keine summe dafür
na das ist doch wie wir hysterie
entwickeln ein jahr lang war hier eine
hysterie kein wissenschaftler behauptet
die erde werde unbewohnbar niemand die
wissenschaft sagt es wird wärmer und das
bitte will ich nicht verhandlungen
das ist alles andere als gut das ist ein
großes problem aber durchdrehen hilft
nicht hier könnte man klima hysterie
diagnostizieren aber nein das geht nicht
mehr klima hysterie ist das unwort des
jahres
ich will das problem nicht kleinreden
ich glaube nur dass hysterie nicht hilft
damit steht der den gegen ton an zum
beispiel zu einer klettertour berg die
sagt hallo anita hofer wanted panik ist
deswegen ein klimawandel leugner
natürlich nicht aber richtet er schaden
an indem er ernst zu nehmen die krisen
öffentlich verharmlost trägt er dazu bei
dass wissenschaftler nicht ernst
genommen werden ich sage also natürlich
ist es besser krisen mit kühlem kopf
anzug aber dabei kommunikation nicht das
zählt was man sagt sondern nur das was
beim anderen ankommt wie es beim thema
klimawandel gar nicht so verkehrt wenn
kreta thunberg sagt amon panik weil wir
da meiner meinung nach weit davon
entfernt sind panik zu schieben also ich
finde wir sind wie zu träge und ich
glaube das liegt daran dass man die
folgen des klimawandels nicht so konkret
sieht wie etwa die sekündlich
verfolgbaren infektions und todeszahlen
bei corona unserem corona geht gerade
erst los video haben wir lange überlegt
wie wir diese ernüchternde message
angemessen so rüberbringen weil wir
angst hatten angst auszulösen ist
natürlich trete ja ich will keine
hysterie oder panik wo dann irrationale
entscheidungen getroffen werden aber ich
will natürlich auch nicht so was auf der
wissenschaft ernst nehmen skala die sich
erstreckt von irrationaler panik bis hin
zu kroner demos in berlin liegt dieter
nur in einem bereich in dem man
verschiedene persönliche meinungen und
wahrnehmungen akzeptieren sollte ohne
dass man sich zustimmen muss also wenn
dieter nuhr findet sie sind so
hysterisch und ich finde die sind nicht
dann ist es halt ansichtssache die man
jetzt schwer faktisch klären kann
zweitens folgt der wissenschaft ist
quatsch denn es gibt in der wissenschaft
nicht die eine wahrheit denn wie sagte
diese philosophin die heute noch kaum
jemand mehr kennt greta hieß sie glaube
ich sie sagte folgt der wissenschaft
aber das ist bei corona nicht so einfach
für die wissenschaftler welt ja denn der
von herrn drosten herrn strick oder
herrn kohl klärt die erste dazu haben
wir natürlich auch ein videoprojekt da
sieht man wie bescheuert dieser satz
schon immer war als wenn es die eine
wissenschaftliche wahrheit gebe und
wegen solcher aussagen haben einige nur
die ski statement dann doch auch
inhaltlich kritisiert und zwar genau
diese stelle hier wissen schafft es
nämlich keine heilslehre keine religion
die absolute wahrheiten verkündet und
wer ständig ruf folgt der wissenschaft
der hat das offensichtlich nicht
begriffen
und wohlgemerkt wird der vergleich
zwischen wissenschaft und religion auch
politisch gerne eingesetzt um
wissenschaftliche evidenz basis
abzusprechen es ging es hier nur um
glaubenssache klima religion zb ist ein
beliebter kampfbegriff von lupenreinen
wissenschafts verweigerern erstens nur
weil es nicht die wahrheit gibt kann man
ja trotzdem folgt der wissenschaft rufen
also dass logan ruft euch auch
wissenschaftliche evidenz und eine eure
meinung wenn es neue erkenntnisse gibt
die zeit ein bisschen sperrig ich habe
gesehen dass ich nur über skurrile
studien lustig macht beziehungsweise
über skurrile schlagzeilen über studien
brauchen galt wissenschaftlich gesehen
immer als gesundheitsgefährdend
jetzt ist es plötzlich gesund das gehört
wer also jetzt ja nicht gesund aber es
hilft gegen korona 99 prozent der korona
toten sind nichtraucher das wäre was für
unser format schlagzeilen
wissenschaftlich geprüft so hört
lustiges bild hat sich alle rauchen
virus schon kommt wenn im kindergarten
alles mit kippe im sandkasten sitzen
stelle ich mir lustig verfolgt der
wissenschaft wer behauptet denn folgt
der wissenschaft hieße folge jeder
x-beliebigen studie das soll man
natürlich nicht mehr an da der recht das
bringt mich zu meinem zweiten punkt
nämlich es gibt zwar nicht die wahrheit
aber es gibt in vielen bereichen
wissenschaftlichen konsens und dem zu
folgen ist nicht religiös das ist
einfach nur vernünftig also eine studie
über krone und rauchen ist kein
wissenschaftlicher konsens dass der
klimawandel menschengemacht ist ist
wissenschaftlicher konsens und natürlich
ist der wissenschaftliche konsens in der
klimaforschung die seit jahrzehnten
betrieben wird viel größer als bei einem
neuen virus das jetzt seit wenigen monat
die welt auf den kopf stellt dritter
wissenschaftliche empfehlungen sind
nicht nachvollziehbar oder realitäts
wären so habe ich ihnen jetzt mal
paraphrasiert am besten kann man das
nachvollziehen in o ton aber den tod an
sich können wir nicht verhindern bei
carola gilt und da ist die statistik
eindeutig die meisten corona opfer sehr
alt vor erkrankt corona ist meist nicht
die ursache des todes sondern nur der
beschleuniger und vieles beschleunigt
den tod jedes bier lässt uns früher
sterben
das nehmen wir hin weil der tod nüchtern
gar nicht zu ertragen ist 350.000
menschen sterben bei uns jährlich an
herz cluster das könnten wir verhindern
eine sport pflicht zwei tasche zwei
stunden am tag oder drei alkoholverbot
sitz verbot tägliche ernährung prüfung
durch ein gesundheits blockwart alle 20
minuten der sms beweglich faule sau wir
hätten hunderttausend tote weniger
das kann man wollen muss man aber nicht
eine ganz ähnliche argumentation brachte
er im januar über die feinstaub debatte
erst mal dass er hier offenbar andeutet
dass corinna nicht so schlimm ist weil
vor allem menschen betroffen sind die eh
bald sterben
ein ganz großes erstens stimmt es ja
nicht also jemand mit einer herz
kreislauf erkrankung mit diabetes mit
einer lungenerkrankung mit einem
geschwächten immunsystem stirbt doch
nicht ewald und zweitens und eigentlich
erster ethik anyone nein was staatliche
schutzmaßnahmen betrifft hat er
grundsätzlich recht ein staat kann die
bürger in einem gewissen rahmen schützen
zum beispiel durch eine gurtpflicht im
auto aber das meiste ist mit guten grund
entscheidungsfreiheit also wo zieht man
da die linie ist ja meine sache wie viel
alkohol trinke wie viele sitze wie viel
sport ich mache aber für mich wie die
sache grundlegend anders sobald ich mit
meinem verhalten andere menschen
gefährdet also zum beispiel finde ich
nicht dass man zigaretten verbieten
sollte aber ich finde es natürlich gut
wenn in restaurants und so weiter
rauchverbot herrscht weil nicht menschen
gegen ihren willen schadstoffe ein haben
sollen und deswegen finde ich auch
crooner schutzmaßnahmen richtig aber das
sind jetzt alles gar keine
wissenschaftlichen fragestellungen mehr
die wissenschaft kann nur feststellen
wie gefährlich oder tür nicht etwas ist
was wir daraus machen
das sind gesellschaftliche politische
ethische fragestellungen und ich weiß
nur act bei vielen an und viele sind
jetzt vielleicht enttäuscht dass ich
nicht auch noch auf diese oder jene
aussage von dem eingehe
aber erstens leute wir haben es gar
nicht so viel zeit nur als ganzes
programm durch zu analysieren der mann
steht seit 30 jahren auf der bühne
respekt dafür aber vor allem wollte ich
versuchen einen wissenschaftlichen fokus
zu legen denn wir erinnern uns es geht
hier um das dfg drama und der vorwurf
dort war unwissenschaftlichkeit also um
teil drei abzuschließen ist dieter nuhr
ein großer freund der wissenschaft
ich würde sagen das ist ansichtssache
aber würde ich nur als wissenschafts
peinlich bezeichnen nein aber das ist
auch nur meine meinung
doch lassen wir mal meinungen hinter uns
und kommen wir zum nächsten punkt wie
wissenschaftlich korrekt ist dieter nuhr
aktiviert dieter nuhr wissenschaftlich
geprüft ich habe mir wie gesagt nicht
alle 30 bühnenjahren von nur angesehen
aber unter den neueren sachen die ich
mir angeschaut habe sind mit direkt ein
paar fehler aufgefallen
drei beispiele fangen wir an mit der
diesel stickoxid feinstaub debatte eine
einzige kerze erzeugt das dreifache des
draußen erlaubten grenzwertes ja das ist
so das ist nicht so der besagte
empfohlen der stickoxid grenzwert von 40
mikrogramm pro kubikmeter ist der
grenzwert für das mittel von einem jahr
der empfohlene grenzwert für eine stunde
liegt bei innenräumen aber bei 200
mikrogramm pro kubikmeter
dh wenn eine kerze 120 mikrogramm
stickoxid produziert überschreitet das
nicht den grenzwert und es recht nicht
wenn man das ganze auch noch durch die
kubikmeter raum teilt denn eine
konzentration ist wohlgemerkt menge pro
volumen zweites beispiel hilft die maske
gegen ansteckungen hilft sie nichts weil
die viren viel zu klein sind die gehen
dadurch wie durch ein offenes
scheunentor die datenlage zu machen ist
erstaunlich schlecht es gibt studien die
haben alle methodische probleme zum
beispiel dass man den effekt der masken
nicht sauber trennen kann von dem effekt
der anderen schutzmaßnahmen aber auch
wenn wir natürlich durch die poren
seiner maske passen ist es nicht
unplausibel dass sie wenigstens einen
teil zu
halten also wenn ich jetzt koste oder
spucke beim reden dann katapultiere ich
ja mal gewähren spucke im zweifelsfall
direkt ins gesicht meines gegenübers und
natürlich hält das wenigstens so eine
maske ab es wäre gefährlich zu denken
dass masken komplett vor der ansteckung
schützen sie sind auch kein ersatz für
den sicherheitsabstand aber es ist auch
gefährlich zu sagen gegen ansteckungen
hilft sie nichts denn überall da wo er
keinen abstand halten kann kann die
maske wenigstens ein teil verhindern
drittes beispiel vom ersten moment an
zum beispiel wusste man beim
robert-koch-institut auf die stelle
hinter dem komma genau wie hoch die
sterblichkeit bei cupid 19 ist obwohl
niemand bis heute weiß wie viele
menschen überhaupt infiziert sind weil
das nur repräsentative tests sagen
können es hat auch niemand ausrechnen
kann wie viel prozent der infizierten
ablehnen da fehlt schlicht und einfach
die wichtigste variable und kenntnis
vorzutäuschen ist nicht wissenschaftlich
und auch nicht seriös und sogar
ärgerlich weil die wissenschaft ist die
einzige wirkliche wissensquelle die wir
haben unter finde ich es schön wenn sie
institutionen wie das lka zum beispiel
nicht den ruf der wissenschaft als es
runter ziehen würden indem sie wissen
vortäuschen wo keins ist er hat recht
dass es bei krone eine dunkelziffer gibt
und dass wir deswegen die infektions
sterblichkeit also die todesfälle
geteilt durch alle infektionsfälle nur
schätzen was das rk ii oder auch die
johns hopkins university berichten ist
die fall sterblichkeit also der anteil
der todesfälle unter den gemeldeten
fällen aber es wird auch nie was anderes
behauptet also im gegenteil gerade am
anfang wurde ich ständig darauf
hingewiesen dass zum beispiel die
fallzahlen mit mehr tests steigen werden
dass dafür die sterblichkeit sind usw
also das erklärt nie vorgegeben oder
vorgetäuscht die reale infektion
sterblichkeit zu wissen oder so
vermitteln ist das stimmt schlichtweg
nicht das muss ja irgendwie falsch
verstanden
ok nur ist comedy ist nicht immer
wissenschaftlich korrekt ist das schlimm
schaden wird im kaum wir messen satire
und comedy nicht an wissenschaftlicher
korrektheit ich finde das natürlich toll
also stellt euch vor jeder der oder die
sich in der öffentlichkeit äußerst
müsste erstmal checken und recherchieren
stellt euch vor allem würden ihre
kommentare erstmals
bevor sie sie irgendwohin kotzen das
wäre eine entspanntere welt aber
bestimmt auch eine weniger witzige
weltall sowie zu sind nunmal portiert
und zugespitzt sie übertreiben und
verkürzen und wenn man das auf
wissenschaftliche themen anwendet ist
das fast schon eine garantie für
wissenschaftliche indirekt wobei ich
natürlich nicht sagen will dass man
wissenschaftlich auch mit humor
vermitteln kann ich meine ich bin ja das
beste beispiel dafür ist doch wohl dazu
will damit nur sagen ich will damit nur
sagen sorry ich finde wir müssen comedy
satire nicht ein wissenschaftlicher
korrektheit messen aber wir müssen so
quellen und medienkompetenz sein satire
über wissenschaftliche inhalte nicht als
wissenschaftliche quelle zu sehen
sondern eben nur als unterhaltung so
aber sollte ein nicht immer
wissenschaftlich korrekte satiriker ein
statement für das wissen für die
deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft abgeben
85 die fdp hätte die dfg nur es gar
nicht fragen sollen aus ihrer sicht
sicherlich ja dann hätten sie sich viel
ärger erspart ist es okay dass die dfg
ein schon für öffentlichen beitrag
wieder löscht war es ja noch mal ganz
andere gewichtung hat als jemanden gar
nicht erst zu fragen sagen wir dass
kampagnen team der dfg wusste nichts um
die kontroversen rund um dieter nuhr und
haben jetzt erst täglich davon erfahren
und haben dann gewisse aussagen von ihm
reviewed und dann gefunden
doch nicht als nicht das passt nicht zu
unserer haltung das finden wir nicht
konsistent was auch immer wenn wir das
gewusst hätten hätten wir gar nicht erst
gefragt wir löschen das jetzt okay aber
da muss man das auch entsprechend
begründen
dessen war bisher die einzige offizielle
begründung wir nehmen die kritik die
vielen kommentaren die hinweise ernst
keine äußerung ob sie der kritik
inhaltlich zustimmen heißt dass der
beitrag wurde gelöscht
einfach nur weil eher unbeliebt war war
schaut euch das an exakt in diesem
moment wo ich es wieder aufnehme
veröffentlich die dfg ein ausführliches
statement sie quasi sagen sorry aber wir
waren einfach nur überfordert und ja ich
denke genau so war es und nicht anders
also an alle die direkt zensur
geschrieben haben
also ruhig mal und die dfg bezieht
ziemlich klarstellung dass sie nicht
stellung beziehen die kritik über den
religions- vergleich haben sie anschein
nach wird so gut verstanden aber möchten
ausdrücklich nicht darüber wer nach
dieser begründung ist die einzig
logische folge dass sie den beitrag
wieder online nehmen was sie die tür nur
in ihrem statement auch anbietet und
zwar im lichte der aktuellen debatte
kommentiert das ist natürlich jetzt
alles sehr unglücklich
dieter nuhr das angebot der tfg
abgelehnt was wenig überraschend ist
auch wenn ich persönlich
zugegebenermaßen nicht auf die idee
gekommen wäre dieter nuhr aktiv
anzufragen finde ich jeder und jede
sollte sich in der öffentlichkeit zu
wissenschaft bekennen dürfen ich denke
ich dass man dafür wissenschaftlich
perfekt sein muss enden jetzt zum
beispiel die grünen die partei der
wissenschaft sein wollen wegen
klimapolitik und so super natürlich weiß
ich dass die grünen und bei themen wie
homöopathie oder grüner gentechnik nicht
dieselbe wissenschaftlichkeit zur schau
stellen aber verlange ich deswegen dass
die grünen ihre verschreibung der
wissenschaft zurückziehen sollen klar
kann man aber ich ziehe es vor die
grünen auf ihre wissenschafts liebe fest
zulage vilas aus unserem team ist zum
beispiel gerne tut und bei dieser
gelegenheit volks glas auf twitter
erster viel aktiver informativer und
lustiger als ich und wer sagt denn dass
dieter nuhr nicht auch mal hier und da
seine meinung ändern kann wenn man ihn
nicht mit beschimpfungen sondern mit
fakten konfrontiert und ihn an sein
statement erinnert zum beispiel haben
sich im märz viele furchtbar über diesen
tweet von dieter nuhr aufgeregt da
immerhin räumte er öffentlich auch ein
viel haben die krankheit unterschätzt
ich im übrigen hoch deutlich zu sagen
deswegen finde ich eigentlich nur gut
wenn sich ein dieter nuhr öffentlich zur
wissenschaft bekennt denn damit lädt er
uns sehr ein
seine arbeit nicht nur anhand von
unterhaltung sondern auch anhand von
wissenschaftlicher korrektheit zu
bewerten und das ist doch eigentlich nur
gut oder hoffe das drama hat der dfg und
der wirklich schönen kampagne wenigstens
ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit gebracht
denn
des nachts ins bett vielleicht in den
skat verlege ich euch unser
wissenschaftler ihren video und ein
video von ranga yogeshwar manga ist ja
seit ich denken kann eine der stärksten
stimmen für die wissenschaft und er hat
mit diesem video statement auch
mitgemacht bei für das wissen
und nachdem er mir im fernsehen seine
nachfolge bei quarks überlassen hat hat
er jetzt mit youtube angefahren was
natürlich mega es ist ganz heiße kanal
im video von mir unbedingt abonnieren
und hinterlasst rang auch gerne viele
liebe kekse von mir
wir sehen uns in zwei wochen bis dahin
bleibt sicher